[Applause]
thank you
thanks very much everyone and it is
great to see you all it is a real
pleasure to welcome you all to Jillian
this morning to a town which for the
first time in at least 50 years is now
run by a labor Council
together
Britain has changed labor has changed
and the challenge ahead not just in
Gillingham but across our country is the
labor to change Britain so where could
be a better place for Kia to set out the
fifth the last but by no means the least
of Labor's missions
the missions we will take from
opposition into government
that will Define our time in power and
by which we expect to be judged
because to believe as we do that
governments can be a force for good but
Power not just for administration but
for transformation is today
distinctively labor only labor has a
vision of how government can Empower us
for those individuals and our society
only labor understands but the purpose
of government is to extend freedoms to
extend opportunities for each of us and
for all of us only labor is clear that
the missions of government are about the
quality of life not for some people
but for everyone
and that determination that drives to
use government for good that is clear
from the missions we have already
announced
the highest sustained growth in the G7
making everyone not just a few better
off
making Britain a clean energy superpower
delivering a net zero future for our
country and our planet for our children
and theirs
building an NHS fit for the future where
everyone lives well for longer making
Britain's Street safe raising confidence
in our police and Justice systems to
their highest level
these are Labor's priorities
safe prosperous Healthy Green future not
for some of us but for all of us
these priorities are very far from what
the current government puts first
you'll have to listen to their speeches
to know that you just have to live here
now there is no greater Mission no more
important Mission no Mission more
clearly labor than the mission we are
here to talk about today
to ensure that opportunity is for
everyone the background is no barrier to
getting on but every child has the best
start in life
for me as a Kia this mission is not
merely the core of our politics
complete person
because I grew up in a town very much
like Gillingham
to building time where yards closed and
deployment vanished
a time when jobs were scared money was
short and poverty all too common
but for me in Washington up in the
Northeast in the midst of all of that I
was lucky
I was lucky because I had a family rich
in love
and a school which sold the value and
worth of each and every one of us that's
that high standards and it saw no reason
why we should not meet them
I have an education which prepared me
not just to face the future but to shape
it
I got the chancellors to succeed
too many of the people around me did not
and I'm here today in front of all of
you introducing here because of that
look
but of course the heart of my politics
everything I hold true but life should
not come down to look that education
must be about opportunity and that
opportunity must be for each of us and
for all of us not for some not for a few
not a society or a few lucky Souls that
pull up from poverty where deep
inequality is justified by humanism and
who is down but opportunity for all of
us
and I know this must not be an idle
dream
to the dream of free and equal Society
is a dream we can and must achieve a
during which the next Labor government
will work tires tirelessly to deliver
and it begins with a better start for
every child
's care and Early Education to support
every family and every child to enable
them to achieve and thrive
High advice and standards in all our
souls because there is no greater engine
of opportunity there are no greater
champions for our young people than the
staff who work in them and there is no
clearer way of making sure our young
people are both ready for work and ready
for life
and that sales and University system
because in too much of our country for
too many of our communities for too much
of our economy too many of our people
are getting the chances they need to
succeed in upskill not just to get by
but to get on
approval it is all about hope The Hope
at roots that Britain's besties lie
ahead of us that our future will be
brighter than our past that is the Hope
at the heart of Labor's ambition for
Britain
and that is why there is no greater
privilege than to introduce the leader
of the labor party the man I know is
ready to be our next prime minister to
set up the brighter future we are
determined to create for each of us and
for all of us the mission or opportunity
which the next Labor government will
deliver here Salma
thank you thank you for those words
thank you for everything that you've
done on this Vision which is so
important to you personally thank you uh
thank you for mid-kent college for
hosting us for being here
[Applause]
which so many of you have devoted to all
lives to so thank you very much for that
now one of the things I learned for my
teachers is that persuasive argument
depends on clear objectives
so let me say that this speech should
demonstrate two things
one that labor has a plan to turn down
the barriers to opportunity that hold
this country and his people back
two that I see this Mission as our core
purpose
and my personal cause
to fight at every stage for every child
the pernicious idea the background
equals destiny
virtual circumstances who you are where
you come from who you know might shape
your life more than your talent your
efforts and your Enterprise
[Applause]
that's what labor is for I've always
told that
very deeply
I grew up in a small town in Southern
England
we had a semi-detached house Pebble Dash
previously
with mum dad all kids four adults and a
blue Ford Cortina outside
not at all
but that's just how life was
but I do look back now would think I've
been on a journey
to go from an ordinary working class
background to Leading the crown
prosecution service and now the labor
party
I feel both privileged
and proud
but over the last year or so I've been
thinking more and more about it
because there's more than a touch of the
1970s about our economic situation
right then we Face a cost of living
crisis that Wars aware of our ability to
move more
so
I think about what it felt like to get
on during that period
about the fact I did see plenty of
people from my background don't want to
achieve their aspirations
and I don't think I'm being too
sentimental to say I grew up surrounded
by
hope
we took it for granted
a sense of Enterprise hard work and
Imagination would be rewarded
believe in tough times this would see us
through that things would get better for
families like ours
now my parents do not believe this
it confidently
it's what everyone wants for their
family
more than a British value
a story we still tell to our children
work hard and you can achieve anything
work hard and you'll get a fair chance
in Britain
the question is
do we still believe it
do you look around our country today and
believe with the certainty you deserve
but Britain will be better for you or
your children
because you should
that's something we should be able to
trust all of this
an Unwritten contract a bond of Hope
between Citizen and Country generation
and generation
so I promise you this whatever the
obstacles to opportunity wherever the
barriers to Hope by the government will
tear them down
questions
and as with all our missions will do so
spurred on by clear and measurable goals
but we didn't change break the link
between where you're starting life or
where you end up but we can measure that
the earnings of our children should not
be determined by those of their parents
[Music]
and make no mistake from where we are
now that's our vicious Target
but it's also urgent this is the world
of artificial intelligence of
technologies that stretch the boundaries
of our imagination
we've got to meet with an open mind to
our gaze towards our children's future
and make sure we're preparing them for
life and work in their
as I said in least listening the
industries of Tomorrow can come to our
thoughts but the rest of the world is
pushing forward as well the race for the
future is unforgiving so we've got to
move past
must unlock the potential that is in
every community so the chance of every
child
and this means we've got to get to the
bottom of a challenge with a long
history
the roots of this are deep
in part it's about security
and especially the diminishing access to
affordable homes
when I say perhaps United Services
to the cost of living crisis we Face
there
will have said in my parasite
that was my springboard
the secure Foundation that gave us
stability
as the world beyond our front door
became more uncertain
it's not Community as well
for a long time now too many people have
had to leave Theirs to find success
how to get out to get on
and when taunted young people start to
leave the town it becomes hard to break
free from that dynamic
it's a vicious cycle
it leads to communities far too many in
this country we're the only job to offer
are low paid and insecure
and its security is the enemy of
opportunity
it places barriers
because many people want not just
pledge we
I came up I was a mission on uh green
power
we are on the side of economic pressure
[Applause]
if you haven't replied
we need a green email right now
upstairs
[Applause]
right now
the single most effective way to get the
green future
[Applause]
not just economic barriers subtle
barriers in the minds of working for you
chips away at stability of family life
but reservoirs of confidence but people
from less privileged backgrounds need to
get on
Twitter said but that's what the cost of
living crisis is doing right now what
the Tory mortgage bombshell is doing
what the total collapse of householding
is doing
but look there's something more
pernicious here
I have a basic idea of barrier in our
Collective mind the Narrows our
Ambitions for working class children it
says
sometimes with subtlety sometimes to
your face
this isn't for you some people call it
the class singly and that's a good name
for it yes economic and security
structural racial Justice surpass it of
course there
but it's also about the fundamental lack
of respect
snorkeling that too often extends into
adults
raising its ugly head when it comes to
inequalities at work in Pay promotion
opportunities
take my dad
foreign
but back in the 1980s
the tour is made it quite clear that
people like him were not valued
but actually they didn't see the point
of our country making things
that his skills were not part of their
future
this hurts it whenever anyone asked that
old question what do you do for a living
I could see him physically pull away
he felt a little down disrespected it
chipped away at his esteem
now I'm not going to pretend that
Thatcher doesn't invented this kind of
snowboard
in truth it's always been there
but what happened back then is with our
economy fundamentally changed our
complacency that we didn't need to
educate all our children because they
could just leave school at 16 and get a
good job in their community that was
exposed almost overnight
this cultural bruise
it still lives and we have to confront
it
the last Labor government had the best
record on education in the history of
our country without pressure
we expanded higher education
fundamentally racial standards gave
millions of working-class children
children of all backgrounds the tools to
thrive their new knowledge economy
but honestly
we didn't exactly this
didn't I rather take a strawberry that
looks now on vocational education
didn't drain them well at disrespect
that creates and that cost us because
when economic success began to Cluster
into your community
where the penalty of not go to
university paid more severe that left us
without a receipts chasing the future
unable to prepare all our children for
work and life in their life
so these are the two fundamental
questions we must now ask of our
education system
are we keeping case with the future
preparing all our children to face it
and all we prepared to confront the
toxic device that maintain the class
ceiling
holding your mind
because
if they were a rumble of concern 13
years ago there are deafening worn out
we should see that has given up on
education
he's not interested in our children's
future if you think that's unfair
then let me remind you what happened
during the pandemic when he as
Chancellor canceled the National
Recovery plan
after our children and working-class
children in particular gave up so much
for the greater good
so for his story about him to turn
around afterwards and repay their
sacrifice with nothing
to sit there twiddling their thumbs as
teachers lead in their dreams school
buildings start to Tumble and
absenteeism goes through the roof
that's shameful
and this is what the tourists don't get
those two questions remember them can we
prepare all our children for the future
will we confront the device and maintain
the car ceiling
they're one on the scene
I'm serious that the sheep and goats
mentality that's always been there in
English education
the academic for my kids vocational for
your kids snobbery
has no place in modern society no
connection to the dogs of the future
no for our children to succeed they need
to be grounded in both need Knowledge
and Skills practical problem solving and
academic
curiosity and the love of learning
that's always been principled
but now as the future rushes towards us
we also need a greater emphasis on
creativity
or resilience or emotional intelligence
and the ability to adapt
all of the attributes but it's starting
to make us human
to distinguish us from learning
make our communities our lives so rich
and rewarded honestly we've got to get
this into our heads
it isn't the case that the status quo
overly fails children outside the
academic room
without modernizing education we're also
thinking that children who do go down
preparing them all for a world that's
receding into the past
so just as I will pull those through
planning yours to rear guide the dream
of homeownership
just as I will take a tough decisions
necessary to win the race for the jobs
of the future rebuild the secure
Foundation opportunity depends upon the
safest streets the cheaper clean
electricity the NHS pick for the future
sustained growth in every community so
too
will I introduce a curriculum fixed with
a digital age so two will I fight for
vocational training to be respected as
much as University education so too will
attract our education system into the
future and shatter the class ceiling
[Music]
so let me set out five areas where a
reformed education system could be the
game changer
five barriers that taken together we
must tear down to prepare our children
for the future
Iowa
the insecurity the right now is
destabilizing family line
education is part of our response part
of the strong Foundation our children
need to get on
most of all in the early years which we
all know from all the evidence are so
crucial to lifelong flourishing
let me tell you about myself this is a
constituent tonight in Canada
also started attending Children's Center
when her son was 18 months old
at the time she was sleeping on her
mom's floor
suffering from depression and what
now thanks to the work of our children's
center kept open by a labor Council
she's managed to get on my feet a
flatter Barone tailored support for her
son now diagnosed with autism on his
language development and a place for him
at the nursery
osop is a parish champion in our
community a life turned around
but now after the wreckage of the past
13 years
her story is becoming rarer and rarer
now I won't miss my words we're building
these Services is going to be difficult
but we can start that Journey with a
clear tongue to boost Child Development
with half a million more children
hitting their early language targets by
2030.
and we will set out the first steps
thousands more Health visitors in the
community
expanding Mental Health Access to new
parents and working with local
authorities to boost capacity in our
child care system
raise standards in Early Education
stop the growing number of nurseries but
right now being forced to shut their
doors for good
Arrow two
confidence
it sounds simple
but all the teachers here will know just
how important it is
in every class there are kids who have
so much ability
what do you struggle to find within
themselves
the confidence to express it the belief
that their ideas matter
the voice to speak up
this is a subtle and significant layer
of the class ceiling don't now
the inability to speak fluently is one
of the biggest barriers for opportunity
and also it's a massive challenge left
behind by the pandemic
particularly in early language
just think for a moment how sad that is
watching those first playful steps
towards expression
has to be one of the greatest joys of
parenting of life
but it must also be one of the greatest
anxieties if your child is struggling
so let's take this off let's raise the
importance of speaking skills Oracle is
some academics called it because these
skills are absolutely critical for our
children's future success
first and foremost of course for
academic attainment
talking through your ideas before
putting them on a page and improve
writing
structured classroom discussion deepens
thinking
but it's not just a skill for learning
it's also a skill for life
not just for the workplace also for
working out who you are
for overcoming shyness or disaffection
anxiety or doubt
or even just for opening up more to our
friends and family
we don't do enough of that as a society
well wouldn't that be something precious
for our children
I think so
confident speaking gives you a Steely
call and a belief to make your case in
any environment
whether that's persuading your mom to
buy some new trainers
a scheduled public to hear your argument
within your daughter to let go of the
opening
it's not foolproof
but we do need to nurture it early in
the early years in Primary School
so today I can announce we will give
every Primary School New funding
paid for by removing tax breaks off
private schools that will let them
invest in world-class early language
intervention help our children find
their voice
I read through an outdated curriculum
the mentality that Cleaves to a
comforter
and services
that refuses to re-examine whether what
we teach our children should keep Pace
with the world outside I say in no
uncertain terms it should
because the race is on
all around the world the best in class
are rethinking their curricula and every
one of them is putting greater
creativity front and center including
countries like Estonia and Singapore
so today we start to capture
we will update the progressive
performance measure and we will use it
to get children studying at creative
arts subject or sport until they are 16.
but we will also go further we'll be
Oracle through a new National curriculum
that finally closes the gap between
learning and life academic and practical
vocational skills school and work
address this
the old way learning out of AIT on 20
year old computers doesn't work
but neither does the new fashion that
every kid should be a covert when
artificial intelligence will blow that
future away
the basic truth is this
to prepare our children for their future
we got to use every opportunity in every
classroom to nurture digital skills
taking a one subject one lesson a week
box simply won't work anymore
so the next Labor government will review
the national curriculum
and today we will set out the principles
of our review
how we must deliver high standards for
every trial
how we must crack the code on digital
skills starting actually early in
Primary School
and how we need every young person
whatever their background to see
themselves in a curriculum with role
models and stories that could Inspire
them to do great things
and look
I know people have been arguing about
this for a long time
and I salute those teachers who over the
past few years have taken their subject
and developed a rich curriculum of
flowing knowledge deep conceptual
understanding foreign
but this debate
about my relative importance of
Knowledge and Skills
people outside the education world are
baffled by him and they're right
everyone with their feet on the ground
in the real world knows
you need both
and these old arguments old practices
all divides they're holding our children
about
most of all
this country's attitude towards
vocational education
ain't never safe this is one of the
deepest rules
and we can't rip it out by ourselves
this has to be a shared undertaking
it's not just businesses colleges and
parents it's the whole of society we've
all been shaped by the class ceiling we
have to remove it
oh there are steps we could take today
first a practical goal that will drive
us home
to give more people than ever access to
the best quality post 19 training
next a proper National skills plan led
by a new body skills income but we'll
work hard in love with our industrial
policy and make sure we can compete in a
race for the jobs of the future
and finally a new growth of skills
learning who doubles down on
apprenticeships high quality Adventures
and that looks again at the full breadth
of formal training available identifies
the best options and gives businesses
greater flexibility to investors
whether that's the tech boot camps that
can train High AI experts in a week the
technical courses that can prepare young
people to be engineered off they need a
clean energy
all the traineeships that can give kids
a foot in the door in the first place
finally five
a soft bigotry of low expectations
an old barrier but one that always needs
more work
is
I know that's something that Michael
Gove said
I didn't agree with everything you did
in education clearly
but when he said that it was an
important strike against the class
ceiling
and acknowledgment that school standards
are the most fundamental Frontline in
the battle for more opportunity
and whatever else you've thought about
education in that period
the tourists simply don't care anymore
they're not interested in raising School
standards how can they be with a number
of teachers leaving the profession is at
record highs
when in parts of the country efforts for
a maths or science teacher could get no
applicants
we've got to turn this around urgently
that's why we'll tackle the retention
crisis by rewarding great new teachers
who commit to a career in the classroom
why will recruit more teachers in
shorter subjects over six and a half
thousand more
and wired to support high standards we
will reform often so it works for
parents and children once more
Safeguard and Revolution happen every
year
our parents deserve a clearer picture on
how their children are being educated
you'll take one word judgment a whole
dashboard this is the formula
effective accountability high quality
teaching a curriculum that prepares you
for life and work that's what labor will
deliver high standards for all of our
children
thank you
so five barriers we can't turn out a new
plan for a new picture the roads respect
and shattering the car ceiling
you know in somerstown in Microsoft
one of the poorest terrorists in London
kids could look out of their window now
the king's cross and Runway Square and
see out there a glittering world of
opportunity
construction everywhere global
technology terms
a whole new city being built just a mile
away
but one that can feel so distant to them
almost another world
I want them to imagine themselves there
and for that to feel natural whatever
there is whatever their background
to think they've been long that success
belongs to them but in this country your
circumstances don't hold you back you
don't have to change who you are just to
get on
and this isn't three zero song game
if we grow the talents of every person
in this country that benefits everyone
think about it sharp elbows the lavatory
the all-consuming fear of failure it
Springs from the same world as my dad's
feeling of disrespect
a rational response perhaps to the runs
of opportunity moving further and
further apart
was an inequality that exhausts people
and this country and unravels the
obligations we hold to each other
this is what my political project my
mission is about
because if we do shatter the castingly
that's the prize
a nation once again a community
a country where we share a stake in
every child not just our own
a Britain with its future back United
Moving Forward Standing Tall to deliver
security backs aspiration opportunity
for all and believes true beliefs that
the future will be better for his
children
thank you
thank you very much we're now going to
take some questions right now I'm going
to come to you first thank you Rigby Sky
News um your mission is to make sure
every child isn't held back by their
background uh you said you want to get
State schools to the same level as
private schools but it needs more than
words it needs resource the National
Association of head teachers have
welcomed your reforms but they have also
said this that it needs significant
additional investment will be needed for
schools that they need the more resource
so will you commit to more investment
for schools and education ahead of the
next general election to fulfill your
mission beyond what you've already set
out thank you about the the approach
I've taken in this Mission and all
Ambitions is to set out the change that
we need to make and why we need to make
it in this case as far as opportunity
and where that evolves finally as this
Mission does to explain how much and
where it's going to come from but
obviously that
um getting rid of the tax breaks for
private schools the vat does yield over
a billion pounds and that we will use
for the jobs of the initiatives it's
about including
recruited 6500 new teachers including
retention payment for existing teachers
and to create the framework in which
they're better perspective so that's the
approach we've taken or on the broader
question funding what I would say is
look the labor government always takes
Education Services it is now possible to
compare these 13 years with the 13 years
under illegal government you could see
the difference the emphasis on education
and the quality of Education that's why
I said what I did about the last
government obviously as we get closer to
an election we will send out the
immediate detail about funding we can't
hide from the fact we're going to
inherit a really damaged economy after
13 years of failure can't hide the fact
that we're going to inherit failed
public services that are on their knees
are on their face after 13 years of
neglect and they have to take hard
decisions but we will set that up as we
go forward and bear in mind and hold it
away
on education thank you Pat Chris I'll
come to you
thank you Chris likes to BBC News
tomorrow's going to see another day of
disruption and miseducation for many
with plenty of teachers out on strike
realistically why should we believe
you'd be any better place to sort this
out given as you acknowledge the
constraints you might inherit
economically because if I was prime
minister
a privilege to be prime minister
Bridget Phillips with the education
secretary of state I would ask how to
tell a require to get it negotiating
every day of the weekly result
[Applause]
thank you Chris
ITV
um you mentioned in your speech school
buildings that are crumbling I.T
equipment that's obsolete not fit for
purpose
all of that show public servants
schools hospitals and Civil Service a
full massively behind the private sector
since
2010. now one of your customer friends
is there's no money to coin a phrase but
I think what people would like to know
is if you win the next election
when would you hope that there will be
money to invest seriously in public
services and and secondly one of your
announcements today that doesn't require
money is changing the national
curriculum uh the general election is
80 months away possibly
why not check or announce those changes
before the election
rather than delay them by saying you
look at them if you win the election
yeah thank you Robert look we are going
to have some very badly damage to call
me there's no doubt about that we have
to make difficult decisions it asks a
question to your questions what are we
going to do about it
um we have to grow the economy and that
can exploring the economy in every part
of the country not just in London and
Southeast and raising living standards
and that that was my mission number one
about the fastest sustainable growth in
the G7 because in a sense that underpins
everything and the other emissions are
all ladder up to that Central Mission
because if we had grown the economy in
the last 13 years as well as we did
under the last minute government we
would have tens of billions of pounds to
spend on our Public Services on
education without making any alterations
to tax and that has to be the central
driving
um Force I have to say that you know not
everything that we need to do is all
about money some of the reforms are not
about money whether it's an educational
in health or just looking about the
other week and there are things that we
can do now we're setting out here of
other curriculum look
um what we want we're determined to do
this review to change our curriculum
um we need to do that in a thoughtful
way in a way that brings the country
where this is the sort of thing that you
should do for two or three years
later so it'll be part of a national uh
debate a consensus about where we go
next I think the case for change is
compelling I've set out the principles
that we would want to underpin the
review but I do think it's better that
review is done in government and we've
got the ability to bring everybody
together behind what will be a really
important change in our education system
thank you Robert I've got um Peter walk
from the guardian Peter hi
um study after study has shown that
child poverty is a massive determinant
of education and social and accuracy of
people when labor came to power in 1907
that was a defined mission that they
brought with them we've now reached the
end of your orthotic missions and the
poverty particular childhood is that's
why
now we'll understand you can't set out
any
physical details until present and time
Peter firstly let me acknowledge the
role of poverty based on TV security in
this and Justice was laser focused on
poverty so will any incoming labor
government some of the issues are set
out to other missions are relevant to
this so for example what we're saying
about housing
affordable housing security
Etc are very very important to poverty
and the economic situation the security
of growing our economy and the way we
will grow it in every community
that's the way to deal with uh poverty
but poverty is all the foundation if you
like but along with others in which
these missions
getting rid of poverty is is a
foundation in which these missions sit
so
um there's in each mission that there
are strands on poverty as in this
Mission but you know the resolve to deal
with policy will be just as great on
income rate of government as it was in
the last local government thank you
Peter a little mirror
hi hi
um
the labor government in Wales and Vernon
seekon the teaching unions and recent
poll showing 89 labor members score on
the sounding free saw meals to primary
school children as I told Lucifer and
she'll get Sergo hungry why wouldn't you
consider it
um
thank you I mean this is a healthy
debate in the country and in the labor
party and obviously a number of councils
only Wales and uh
committed to it we take a different
route which is to go down the roots of
breakfast clubs and other structures for
of course we want to move forward but
you know we are constrained by the
economics and we orchestrate also by
this question of whether that is the
best targeting of the resources that
we've got but uh we boil down through to
breakfast clubs but other councils of
Wales have gone uh it's a debate we
should welcome as an ongoing debate
about what's the best way here to move
forward thank you listen I've got
Harriet from The Daily Mail
today about the cost of living pressures
facing companies across the country do
you agree as your candidate in Uxbridge
says that now is not the right time to
expand you less thank you very much for
that Daddy bills is our candidate in
Uxbridge group of candidate to
um and he is rightly raising concern on
behalf of what he hopes will be his
constituents in relation to you less
because we all understand the impact as
financially I think it's important when
we have this discussion to to properly
recognize the context there is a legal
requirement to deal with evolution
um so it's not just a political choice
that is made in the abstract it's
document and that's my viewers because
the first US was introduced uh by Tory
mayor so you know for the purpose of the
violations is being used as a party
political tool but actually the legal
framing of it is there in legislation
which nobody can escape and the first to
put a u.sc in place were actually a tour
Administration so
it's right to to
um say what he said in sitting up for
what he had to be as constituents thank
you Harriet I've got seven daily
interests thank you so far from Daily
Express there are concerns that gender
unusual toilets in schools increase the
risk of girls being harmed do you
believe schools must have single sex
Twitter and then if I may would
secondary schools need to inform parents
we have to have questions their gender
identity under a labor problem
to guidance it would be calling for
guidance for a very
a year ago
and they still haven't done so so
um I urge them to get on with that right
so we can then all look at it and debate
it against what the guidance is and
um yeah I say to the government yet
again bring that guidance forward
we can walk move forward in a way which
puts protection and well-being of
children but it's art and not political
Point scoring thank you very much
congratulations
you talk about growing the economy but
parents usually women that are dropping
out of the workforce to pay for
extortionate child care how would you
make childcare more affordable
as well so we have set out
um the sort of down payment in what in
relationship what we'll do on child care
of course we'd like to go further
because it is very very important but
Bridget's already set them out it sort
of underpins this Mission rather being
the central part of what I set out this
morning but it is crucial to it thank
you very much uh Jack from the Sun
RC
you know particularly this last week
they've been interrupting iconic Sports
implements causing massive disruption
there's a huge Arrow events involved but
they're the only people who understand
the argument their tactics the area
and when I put what they're doing
against what we set out in our mission
about clean energy about Net Zero you
could see the difference between
um you know protest and power that
gluing yourself interrupting interfering
with other people's lives in this
arrogant way compared with the actual
term that can bring around which is
where the labor government absolutely
committed to clean Power by 2030. thank
you very much I thought Dominic from the
telegraph
um in January labor pledged to put the
money from scrapping charitable stages
for private schools you pledge that you
send that on 6500 new staff today you're
spending it on various outfits in
schools earlier this week you said you
would spend it on sort of golden hello
East teachers to to 2500 per teacher
he's just making the same money three
times and further till you turn on green
energy the latest in a line of Liberty
u-turns how can voters trust you any
more than the protesters earlier well
look firstly on the money the by
abolishing the tax break for private
schools that heals over a billion that's
more enough and adequately covers the
commitments that we've made one of the
things that we do on this Mission
launches is to publish a supporting
paper which interview the gospel will
soon have which sets out exactly what
each of these commitments costs and how
that might come from the number one
billion secondly on the
um a question of green power there's
nobody to turn then back down we've
doubled down because I gave a mission to
say there are five there are five big
things that an incoming labor government
is going to do the Purpose Driven whole
point of these missions is these are the
five things that matter most this is the
change that you can expect to see after
five or ten years of a labor government
and when it comes to difficult decisions
we will prioritize the emissions over
other things that's a little bit tough
so when I set it out because my fourth
Mission clean power 2030 that is not
that's that's doubling down on it uh
particularly over 28 billion pounds
which is huge amount to invest for the
future so the framing I just don't
accept I think most people look at that
mission and say if we could achieve that
ambition that is the route to lower
bills to energy security because people
like putting might be able to put boots
on our clothes so the next generation of
skills and jobs
and of course what we need to do in
order to meet town at zero obligations
so I think that's very ambitious Mission
and not many people who've heard that
speech or looked at our mission and said
to me you're not going far enough motion
said whoa that is going to be a real
hard thing to achieve here but if you
can achieve it the prize is fantastic so
I don't accept that um
pop here from the island
tuition fees and come up with any plan
that affects the current broken system
you still haven't done so reset research
shows that the poor students tend to be
University were far higher debt than
their more Advantage appears can you
really say that labor will smash the
glass ceiling while saddling poor
University students with tens of
thousand pounds of debt but we've got to
change the the tuition police system
because it is unfair I think at least it
changed and we are going to put forward
a plan for the cost of plan to show how
we're going to do that so we will set
that out in due course and obviously and
take any questions at the time in
relation to it and it is very important
for reasons that everybody understands
in terms of the debt that young people
at the moment carry with them but I
would also say this
uh whilst I do want more and more people
because University and obviously for me
a big person like 100 Persian person it
was a really big thing for me and my
family
equally I'd want people to particular
vocational groups than technical skills
the apprenticeships
Etc and for that to be equally valued
and therefore this issue of um nutrition
fees is part of the ultimate but it
cannot be construed in a way I don't
think there's a whole of the argument
because that would leave out to account
all those people who don't go to
university so we will set our plans
and you know we are constrained you know
when I say and I've said this
a number of times now that the country
we inherit if we are privileged enough
to come into power
I mean the economy will be damaged
really apparently down the damage this
is not 1997 where the economy was
growing this is a really badly managed
economy after 13 years of very little
growth exacerbated by that kanikaze
budget with public services not on the
knees but on their face that means that
we will have to take difficult decisions
and that we may not be able to do all
the things that an incoming labor
government would want to do as quickly
as we would like to do because that is
what we inherit what I'm saying out is
that based on which we will take our
country forward
um and the change that you know people
can expect to see after five years and
the idea of a mission is this sense of
driving purpose so we don't get knocked
off course so we can measured against it
um and so that we can take priorities
and decisions about priorities in a
consistent and coherent way and frankly
if we had anything like the strategy
uncertainty that I'm setting out now in
the last 13 years we wouldn't really
utter mess that we're in we're going
round around a circle chopping and
changing complete failure if five Prime
Ministers four chances of last year this
may be politically amusing for the
future security of the country it's a
disaster
[Applause]